manifestations grèves des audiences code
civil brûler les avocats balancent leurs
robes
il plaide contre l'intégration de leur
caisse de retraite autonome au régime
universel
on a une caisse autonome qui marche
parfaitement bien qui est gérée depuis
des dizaines d'années par les avocats
pour les avocats et on nous a annoncé la
disparition notre régime dans des
conditions complètement qu'on bouscule
et malgré toutes les demandes qu'on a pu
qu'on a pu faire auprès des autorités
on n'arrive pas à avoir des réponses sur
le devenir de notre autonomie
cette réforme aura pour conséquence de
multiplier par deux les cotisations de
près 40% des avocats en france des
cotisations qui passeront de 14 à 28 %
des charges trop lourdes pour les petits
cabinets indéniablement les avocats sont
une profession libérale économique sont
des chefs d'entreprise nous sommes 60 me
en france et il y à de nombreux avocats
qui ont des difficultés économiques qui
ne pourront pas faire face à la hausse
de cotisation qui est annoncé une hausse
de cotisations pour à la suite avoir
moins de droit au niveau de la retraite
évidemment donc c'est un double problème
et une réforme qu'ils jugent utiles
légitime pour cause la caisse nationale
des barreaux français est excédentaire
de deux milliards d'euros et ne coûte
rien à l'état
mais de son côté le gouvernement
n'entend pas reculer ce que souhaite le
gouvernement s'est instauré un régime
universel tous les français doivent
l'intégrer
les avocats aussi pour nous ce n'est pas
négociable
et conséquence de la grève une justice
au ralenti retard des dossiers
comparution immédiate interrompu procès
reporté au tribunal correctionnel de
bobigny 40% des affaires ont dû être
repoussée d'un an des avocats prêt à se
défendre encore longtemps
la lutte va continuer jusqu'à la fin
nous irons jusqu'au conseil
constitutionnel au conseil d'état on ne
contestera le régime bon la lutte va
continuer les nouvelles actions
aujourd'hui il bat à nouveau le pavé à
paris le jour du début des travaux
parlementaires sur le projet de loi
[Musique]